Ciao ragazzi bentornati a un nuovo video
qui sul mio canale, oggi ho pensato di
fare un esperimento ed è un esperimento
sportivo. Ho pensato di trascinare
all'interno di questa esperienza i miei
fratelli e Luigi, che io voglio vedere
alle prese con uno sport un pochino
alternativo. Sto parlando della pole dance
E' partito? - Si (Enrico) - Io pure voglio partire, via
da qua
Principalmente io faccio la
parte dei tricks e delle combinazioni al
palo sia static che spin
Bellissimo, ma domani... - Starai malissimo si
- Cioè perché io vedo Lavinia che a volte sembra che è stata malmenata pesantemente
- Quello perché ogni tanto vengo qui e loro mi picchiano e basta
Salire sul palo non è come salire
su un albero, cioè è una tecnica folle
è impossibile! - E pancia al palo, subito pancia al palo. Subito su. Fai salire le mani caro
- Però ragazzi...no aspetta aspetta aglia...no non ce la faccio
- Credo che i super scilla bros ti stiano stracciando (Enrico)
- No aspetta aspetta, mi sta venendo l'ansia, aspetta rifallo... Vai fammi vedere come lo fai te (Gu)
Aspetta Ga credo che sia questo il palo che forse devo usare
Bravo! (Lavinia) - Bravo!... Vai vai vai su vai su (Angela)
A un certo punto pur di scappare mi sono
mimetizzato con l'ambiente
Vai Gu (Enrico)
Io sono la pippa e quei due so bravissimi, questa è la verità...bello!
La static è un po' come fare calisthenics su una
scopa, scomodo
Questo è uno sport dove si affacciano
tutti i tipi di persone, anche quelle che
non hanno mai fatto nulla, e quindi devi
andare per gradi, non può iniziare... Anche
una persona che comunque sia ha un
background sportivo importante come una
ballerina o un atleta di ginnastica
artistica comunque sia si trova con uno
strumento che non ha mai usato, lavora con
uno strumento verticale
- Mamma mia Già ha veramente oh! (Enrico)
Io mi faccio male - Cioè si sta tirando indietro quindi         - Ma tanto adesso lui recupera con Exotic - Si, Exotic
E' il tuo turno, mi raccomando (Enrico) - E' il mio momento
Perché hai iniziato pol dance? (Enrico)
Io perché l'ho iniziata? Per caso
per puro caso, perché ho iniziato a insegnare
danza in questa scuola
Io non volevo farla, mi ha convinto
Simona - La scuola si chiama Vertical
Dolls, è un brand, abbiamo tante sedi su Roma e altre sedi
in tutta Italia e anche delle sedi
all'estero, quindi è un franchising a
tutti gli effetti. Donne il 90 per cento,
il 10 per cento ti potrei dire uomini
Guglielmo pure se l'è cavava dai - Una risposta onesta (Gabriele) - Forse deve fa un po di stretching Guglielmo
Aiutiamoci finché è possibile... Aiuto!
- E invece Luigi? (Enrico) - Ancora di più di Guglielmo
- E invece sul ritmo? (Gabriele) - Assolutamente Guglielmo!
Era lanciatissimo, si muove pure bene
- E gli altri? (Gabriele)
Mi guardo attorno, il deserto! Gabriele
che secondo me è un jet lag di 7 minuti
cioè lui continua a fare i passi dei
sette minuti prima. Poi abbiamo Gianluigi
si attacca al palo ma il suo palo è
attaccato alla corrente perché ha delle
specie di spasmi. Lu non lo comprendo - Un pochino rigidi...però ci si può lavorare
- E come convinzione (Gabriele) - Come convinzione direi Luigi
Diciamo che è una disciplina che ti
spinge a uscire abbastanza dalla tua
confort zone - Gu ti prego di a Gabriele di mettersi il tacco (Enrico)
Sei l' unico che può mettere il tacco (Enrico) - Sei l'unico che può farlo (Gu) - Vai a mettere il tacco! (Enrico)
Allora i tacchi no, i tacchi col c***o che me li metto
- E' bruttissimo!
Oddio volo!
- Ma questo dito deve sta così stretto?
No non riesco a muove questo dito Erlè
Scusate, scusate, una ragazza che però dimostri, perché sennò chi copia?
Passeggiamo però
- Grazie per i tacchi eh - No grazie per averli provati
- Io non ho fatto sport per 11
anni, questo insieme a tanti altri
problemi, quindi sfoghi sul cibo eccetera, mi ha
portato anche ad accumulare peso, a non
accettare me stessa. Io rifiutavo lo
specchio anche prima di entrare in
doccia per dire. Quando mi dissero
"Andiamo a provare pole dance" io venni
solo per accompagnare un'amica, cioè
"Cioè chi mi metto a fare, nemmeno faccio
le scale per salire" e abito al primo piano.
Arrivo, incontro Angela, subito dico
"Ok però aspetta, questa persona mi sta
facendo fare delle cose e ci riesco e
non mi sono sentita troppo brutta quando mi sono guardata allo specchio. Come ero vestita? Avevo
dei pantaloncini da basket da uomo fino
al ginocchio e una maglietta da uomo con
le manicone lunghe, però sul palo devi
avere la pelle a contatto per molte cose
altrimenti cadi. MI sono iscritta, ho
iniziato a riandare una volta a
settimana, poi vedevo che miglioravo e piano piano
piano piano, andavo sempre a comprarmi
pantaloni sempre più corti
- Che stai facendo? (Enrico) - No volevo vedere quale prendere per segnarmi...Come lo vedi questo Già?
Questo secondo me per te sarebbe perfetto!
- No, poi mi tocca... - Lu, Lu, un verde con un violino smeraldo, un verde smeraldo così "sirenetta"
Ok io opterò per il blu - Nono questo Luigi, gli prende gli occhi. Vedi che mi manchi delle basi? Guarda
Finché dopo praticamente sei mesi che avevo
iniziato le mie amiche mi hanno
obbligata letteralmente a spogliarmi,
perché comprai un completino fatto
apposta da pole e sono tipo costumi no?
Però non avevo la minima intenzione di
rimanere con quello, cioè io lo mettevo sotto
come portafortuna, non lo so perché mi sentivo
che avevo questa cosa sotto. Niente mi
hanno presa, mi hanno bloccata, mi hanno
spogliata, mi hanno fatta vedere allo
specchio e mi ha detto "Adesso ci devi
spiegare perché tu non ti metti così". Ti
permette di liberarti da tutte le tue
paranoie sul tuo corpo e piano piano ci
riesci. Ho cambiato il punto di vista nel
guardare il mio corpo, cioè non lo
giudico più in base alla bellezza ma alla
funzionalità. E questo mi permette di
venire a lezione con un sorriso pazzesco
io mi spoglio, non vedo l'ora di
spogliarmi per fare l'esercizio, quindi
l'approccio col mio corpo è cambiato tantissimo,
e ci sono riuscita in anni di terapia
quindi non penso sarei riuscita in altro
modo in così poco tempo in un anno a
cambiare completamente come vedo me stessa
- E allora la mia passione per la pole dance è nata
in maniera
strana, particolare, perché di fatto nasce
da un lutto, si potrebbe dire
Io avevo una nonna, che amavo tantissimo e che mi manca tanto adesso
Lei purtroppo per problemi
fisici dovuti ovviamente all'età
non riusciva più a muoversi come avrebbe voluto
Qualche volta in televisione passava, che
ne so il Cirque du Soleil
quindi questi acrobati bellissimi, e lei
diceva "Che bello, quanto mi piacerebbe
poterle fare queste cose! Io ormai ho
fatto il mio tempo, non mi posso
più muovere. Ma tu perché, perché tu non
ci provi? Perché sarebbe bellissimo
sarebbe bellissimo vederti volare così.
E quindi quando purtroppo lei è venuta a
mancare mi sono decisa a fare questa cosa
e a superare anche un po' questi limiti
che per esempio nel mio caso era la paura
dell'altezza o la paura di stare a testa
in giù. Io non mi sono mai arrampicata
nemmeno su un albero per dire e adesso
mi arrampico a tre metri e venti di altezza e
sono molto felice e mi sembra di aver
fatto anche un regalo non solo a me
stessa ma anche a mia nonna e sono
convinta che mi guardi e sia felice per me
Le passioni secondo me hanno il potere
veramente di curarci. Una delle cose che
questa esperienza mi ha ricordato è che
effettivamente siamo troppo abituati a
pensare veramente dalla copertina di
aver letto tutto quanto il libro
Provare nuove cose non è solamente un modo per
tenersi occupati ma è anche un modo per
scoprire nuovi aspetti di noi. Io veramente
credo che il mondo non veda l'ora di
stupirci e che l'unica cosa che dobbiamo
fare è veramente uscire di casa
Io come sempre vi lascio tutti quanti i
link delle persone che mi hanno aiutato
e che sono state disponibili e per la
realizzazione di questo video
Invito a seguire questo canale, attivare la
campanella delle notifiche ma soprattutto
in questo caso, se non vi rompe, farmi
sapere che cosa ne pensate di un format
di questo tipo. Se avete dei suggerimenti, in che cosa vi
piacerebbe vederci coinvolti a me e alla mia famiglia
Vi ringrazio di cuore ancora perché
siamo vicinissimi a questo milione che per
me ha così tanti zeri che non riesco
nemmeno a vederli tutti quanti insieme
così a botta d'occhio. E che dire ci
vediamo la prossima volta, che ancora
sarà una grande incognita, perché non so
che cosa faremo ma è
un esperimento che voglio portare
avanti ed è un modo per, insomma
cimentarsi in nuovi contenuti e cercare
un pochino di rendere questa piattaforma
sempre più diversa e nuova.
Fino ad allora vi auguro una
buona giornata e che dire, ci vediamo la
prossima volta con un prossimo, con un
prossimo video, prossimamente. Sembro Luca Giurato, vabbè non lo so chiudere
Basta finiamo così. Ciao